[Music]
we love Disney characters just the way
they are but one tumblr artist named
titi from let there be doodles decided
it was time that a few of them be
redesigned in unique ways get ready to
see your favorite characters in a new
light will show you their new appearance
and some even change their gender from
male to female and vice versa just wait
until you see Christoph's brand new look
you'll be intrigued and amazed at the
same time if you're new to our channel
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're sharing 10 Disney characters as
they would appear in alternate universes
Alice even though Alice in Wonderland is
considered a classic film today it
wasn't well received when it was first
released you see the movie was based on
an English novel written by Lewis
Carroll many people were upset about
Disney's Americanization of the movie
even Walt Disney agreed the film wasn't
that great but decades later we've all
come to appreciate this eccentric
masterpiece in the original film Alice
wears her signature outfit it includes a
blue knee length dress with a white
apron on top she also wears white
stockings black Mary Jane shoes and a
tiny black bow in her beautiful blonde
hair when it comes to her features
Disney designs her to have big blue eyes
that are wild and very expressive okay
now it's time to see the new Alice in an
alternate universe here she is
that's right Alice is now a little boy
the character's hair is still blonde but
it's much shorter in this new image the
eyebrows are a bit thicker the lips are
thinner and the nose is a bit more
pronounced as a boy Alice still has a
love for the color blue but the
character wears a blue shirt with blue
and white striped suspenders instead the
black bow that Alice usually wears in
her hair is long gone but in the new
image the boy version of Alice wears an
adorable bowtie too
please his outfit genie in the 1992 film
Aladdin the world was introduced to the
magical and powerful genie like most
Disney characters the genie was living
in a world he so desperately wanted to
escape he lived inside an oil lamp but
his ultimate wish was to be free with
his cosmic powers he granted Aladdin
three wishes and Aladdin used his third
wish to set the GB free the character
has a very recognizable look honestly
it's hard to miss him he's a brilliant
blue color
he has very pointy ears a hooked nose
and a black beard with a tiny curl on
the end he's lacking in the hair
department except for a single ponytail
that stands straight up on top of his
head now hold on to your seat we're
about to show you genies brand new look
and here it is he's now a voluptuous
woman the single ponytail has been given
new life look at how much hair the
character has as a female also her lips
are much plumper her nose is sharper and
she has a curvy body her fingernails are
nice and long and she's dressed in an
Arab style outfit what do you think of
the female version of genie reacting the
comment section down below
Ursula Ursula already looks like she's
from an alternate universe don't you
think the half human half octopus
villain from The Little Mermaid has an
appearance that's a bit frightful and
she also has a pretty vicious attitude
to go right along with it the sea witch
has a dark sense of humor
she loves to wreak havoc in Atlantica
especially when it comes to Ariel the
mermaids happily ever after was almost
ruined when Ursula morphed into Vanessa
and attempted to marry Prince Eric thank
goodness her plan failed despite
Ursula's cruel and vindictive ways we're
still anxious to see what she would look
like if her appearance was completely
transformed are you ready to see what
she would look like in an alternate
universe well here she is as a man
Ursula has the same
skin color and the same hair but her
eyelashes are gone and her lipstick has
been removed also the male version is
sporting some pretty interesting facial
hair he actually has a beard made of
tentacles what do you think of the new
Ursula do you think the character looks
just as good as a male character let us
know your thoughts down below in the
comment section Hercules when you think
of a brave strong and powerful Disney
character you probably instantly think
of Hercules the star of the 1997
animated film has some pretty amazing
strengths but even though he has big
muscles he has an even bigger heart the
character is very sweet and
compassionate especially when it comes
to the ladies but there's only one woman
who holds the key to his heart and
that's mogera his loyalty towards her
was unwavering how could we forget when
he went to the underworld and saved her
even after he felt betrayed now that's
what we call true love the character
wears a Roman warrior outfit including
his armor and a pair of sandals he has
light brown hair and big blue eyes he's
basically the stereotypical male hero
so we're shocked to see what he looked
like reimagined in an alternate universe
the big and bulky character was
transformed into a stunning heroine her
hair is still like round but it's curly
and much longer her nose is a bit
smaller her lips are plumper and she
even has some dainty ears we're really
digging this feminized version of
Hercules how about you
Cruella Deville Cruella Deville may be a
cruel villain but she's still one of the
most popular animated characters in
Disney history the fashion-obsessed
character made her debut in the 1961
film 101 Dalmatians since then she has
been known for her fur her multicolored
hair and her raspy voice it sounds like
nails on a chalkboard don't you think
her wicked voice has the ability to send
chills down your spine it's hard to
imagine Cruella looking any different
from the way she appears in the classic
film but artist titi
made it happen on the blog let there be
doodles TT posted this amazing Photoshop
version of karela to transform her from
a female into a male the new Cruella
still has a love for fashion he wears
this same fur coat
but his outfit underneath has changed a
bit he looks very dapper in his tie vest
collared shirt and red gloves as a male
karela has the same chiseled face and
squared jawline the character's hair is
still two-toned
but it's much shorter on the male
version also he's sporting some
perfectly groomed facial hair we're
really loving this new version of
Cruella de Vil how about you Prince Adam
Prince Adams story was truly
heartbreaking his entire world was
flipped upside down after he was cursed
by The Enchantress in the 1991 film
Beauty and the Beast the prince had to
learn how to love and earn loved in
return
before he was freed from the curse as we
all know he fell in love with Belle and
this fairy tale concluded with a very
happy ending in human form the character
is very handsome he has a wavy brown
hair that reaches his shoulders and
dazzling blue eyes he has a square jaw
line a wide nose and some pretty full
lips we're now about to show you the
princes new appearance get ready because
you're about to be shocked here's the
prince transformed into a beautiful
female as you can see the character
still has the same good looks as if
female her hair is still wavy but it's
much longer she has the same blue eyes
but now she has some pretty eyelashes to
go along with them she has a cute little
button nose and lips that have been
covered in some bright lipstick do you
think Prince Adam looks better as a male
or a female we'd love to see what you
think down below in the comment section
meridah meridah stole our hearts in the
2012 movie brave the character is a lot
different from the other princesses in
the Disney lineup she's far from being a
damsel in distress she's strong
free-spirited and
and shoot a bow and arrow with the best
of them she has no desire to be a proper
royal she'd much rather practice her
archery skills horse racing and sword
fighting her appearance is absolutely
breathtaking she has a head full of wild
and curly red hair big blue eyes and
thin lips she also has adorable rosy
cheeks pink lips and a small hint of
freckles on her face now close your eyes
are they closed okay we're about to show
you a different version of Merida open
your eyes on the count of three one two
three here she is Merida's entire
appearance was photoshopped and she has
gone from a princess to a prince the new
Merida's hair is much shorter but it
still has its full and bouncy curls the
face on the boy version is a bit slimmer
the lips aren't as pink and the nose is
brighter we love the way the original
Merida looks but her male counterpart
looks pretty amazing too don't you agree
Aladdin even though Aladdin was born a
street rat he didn't let his unfortunate
childhood bring him down the star of the
1992 animated film has a very warm heart
despite all of his struggles when it
comes to his appearance the character is
slender with very dark features he has a
head full of black hair thick eyebrows
and big brown eyes you have to admit
he's very handsome we've grown to love
him just the way he is
but we're anxious to see what you would
look like in an alternate universe how
about you well we don't have to wonder
any longer we found an image of Aladdin
that will take your breath away
here it is Aladdin has received a gender
makeover and he's no longer the boy he
used to be
he's now all woman and he's equally as
beautiful the new female version of the
Disney character has the same dark hair
and big brown eyes but she wears some
winged eyeliner that really makes her
eyes pop her eyebrows are a bit thinner
to frame her face and her nose is a lot
small
her lips are plump and they have a pale
pink tint to them the shape of her face
has also been altered her chin is much
shorter to soften up her features as for
the style of her hair it's now much
longer it's worn to the side so it can
delicately cascade down her shoulder
Christophe big burly and husky are a few
of the words that could be used to
describe Christophe Prince's Ana's love
interest in the movie frozen is
adventurous fun-loving and he has an
intense fascination with ice it's no
surprise he has such a masculine
physique he can thank his years as an
ice Harvester for his bulging muscles he
has blonde hair that's styled in a short
cut big brown eyes and a few freckles on
his pale skin he has a rather large nose
but it's in proportion with the rest of
his features it fits his face quite
nicely don't you think even though he's
the epitome of a strong man the artists
titi recreated Christophe in a way you'd
never believe here he is as a woman how
beautiful does the new Kristoff look as
a female the characters features have
been softened to make her appear much
more feminine her hair is now much
longer even though she still has bangs
she also has a side braid too
her eyes are about the same size but she
has the luminous lashes to make them
stand out even more her nose is a bit
smaller and her lips are a tad bit
fuller and check out her jewelry that's
a pretty cool snowflake earrings she's
wearing don't you think Snow White in
1937
Snow White was born today she's
considered to be the very first Disney
Princess as the main character in Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs the young
character is so innocent and vulnerable
it's her sweet nature and kindness that
makes her a favorite among the forest
animals and the dwarfs although she had
to deal with some harsh conditions at
home she still remained kind and
optimistic
she wasn't about to let her evil
stepmothers jealousy bring her down the
character has a slender frame and she
wears a signature court dress
it has a blue bodice big puffy sleeves
and a high collar her hair is short and
dark brown but she adds a bit of color
to it with some help from a bright red
bow her skin is fair and her lips are
red but can you imagine if Snow White
was a prince instead of a princess
well we have a photo that depicts the
Disney character as a boy here he is his
hair is still dark but it's much shorter
the male version of Snow White has no
eyelashes and smaller lips his face has
a more prominent jawline and his chest
is more defined what do you think of
this gender-bending version of Snow
White in an alternate universe we'd love
to read your thoughts in the comment
section which of these disney characters
in alternate universes is your favorite
react in the comment section down below
if you enjoyed this video and you'd love
to see more just like it
make sure to subscribe and give us a big
thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]